alors il n'y aura donc aucun
représentant canadien aux cérémonies
d'ouverture et de fermeture des jeux à
pékin quel est l'impact réel d'un
boycottage comme celui là surtout en
période de qu'ovide il ya une roche et
professeur au département de géographie
de l'uqam et expert en géopolitique du
sport mais sur roche bonsoir soit alors
qu'est ce que concrètement un boycottage
peut changer est ce que ça peut vraiment
faire bouger la chaîne sont les droits
de la personne je pense que ça a déjà
été dit dans le reportage tout à l'heure
je pense que personne ne s'attend à ce
que ça bouge de manière vraiment
importante l'important était de marquer
le coup et de ne pas laisser les choses
se déroulaient comme la chine avait
envie de le faire c'est à dire sans
aucune anicroche sans aucune réaction de
la part de la communauté internationale
par contre tout le monde a bien
mentionné que les et je pense qu'il y
avait un consensus là dessus c'est que
l'idée d'un boycott sportif qui avait
déjà marqué ses limites à à moscou et à
los angeles en 91 84 sa tous montés da
et est la cour mais il fallait faire un
geste donc est-ce que ça peut quand même
bon c'est un message qu'on envoie à la
chine si je vous comprends bien mais est
ce que ça peut faire mal à la chaîne
quand même parce que ces jeux sont
importants pour elle tout à fait c'est
très important pour la chine a déjà
commencé à utiliser un petit peu sa
machine à image pour promouvoir ces jeux
indique x à l'aide des treks des très
grands enjeux sécuritaires que ça les
montrer à quel point la chine était un
très grand pays il compte beaucoup là
dessus pour continuer une stratégie de
l'image et le fait d'avoir ce boycott
diplomatique ne va surtout leur faire
perdre un tout petit peu la face si on a
vu comment ils essaient de le minimiser
parce que c'est surtout en terme d'image
que ça peut que ça peut jouer ça
changera pas du tout la politique de la
chine où il peut y avoir des mesures de
représailles non ça changera pas la
politique
vous avez des ouïghours par exemple je
pense que non très sincèrement
j'espère me tromper mais au contraire il
depuis longtemps il analyse la situation
comme étant une mesure de propagande
menée par les états unis et leurs alliés
que ce sont des mensonges que tous les
observateurs étrangers qui sont rendus
là bas se sont rendus coadou qui est ce
qu'ils sont neutres se sont rendu compte
qu'il n'y avait rien que ce sont des
centres de formation professionnelle
donc à ce niveau là pour eux ils n'ont
rien fait de mal tout se passe bien et
c'est simplement une mesure menée par
les américains et leurs alliés et le
canada apparemment donc se retrouve
comme un allié très docile des états
unis et est ce que le canada doit
craindre des représailles parce que la
chine a déjà dit qu'il y aurait des
conséquences il ya de fortes chances que
le canada est à craindre des
représailles surtout que la manière dont
les choses se sont passées c'est à dire
que les etats unis se sont exprimés dans
un premier temps ensuite il ya eu
l'australie et le royaume uni le canada
avait parlé de d'attendre un petit peu
on est même parlé d' encore quelques
jours avant de se décider et l'idée
c'est qu'au lieu de d'apparaître dans un
front commun le canada l'air de suivre
les états unis alors que ça faisait déjà
longtemps qu'on s'était exprimé au
canada notamment février à la chambre
des communes par rapport il y avait une
motion qui était passé à l'unanimité
pour condamner ce qui se passait mais là
la manière dont les choses se sont
passées le canada apparaît comme un pays
qui suit les états unis et rappelez vous
avec l'histoire des deux michael et de
manjul où on est déjà un peu dans le
collimateur de la chine n'est pas
impossible donc oeil et des mesures de
rétorsion sans doute économique et est
ce que le canada d'après vous donc
aurait dû agir plus vite parce que
certains on parle de ça ça fait ça fait
longtemps qu'on en parle d'un boycottage
possible je sais pas comment ça a été
comment ça s'est passé dans les
coulisses en quelque sorte de toute
manière c'était déjà évoqué depuis très
longtemps je pense que le canada pouvait
même pas y aller après tout ce qui
s'était passé il pouvait pas y aller de
manière tout à fait tout à fait nous
comme si rien ne s'était passé par
contre il aurait sans doute fallu et je
suppose que peut-être que certaines
personnes ottawa regrette la manière
dont les états unis ont peut être géré
les choses de manière pas très
consensuel mais rappelez-vous qu'en 2008
l'abbé jean stephen harper ne s'était
déjà pas présente et donc des idées
politiques diplomatiques ou du moins
partielle ça a déjà été fait mais cette
fois là ce avait été il savait même menu
une rafraîchissement des tensions entre
le canada et la chine en ce moment et en
ce moment les relations déjà très
tendues entre le canada et la chine donc
ça ça va pas s'améliorer facilement
nancy roche merci beaucoup c'est moi qui
vous remercie bonne soirée bonsoir